las negociaciones para un alto el fuego
entre rusia y ucrania continúan y
también empiezan a despejarse algunas
dudas como por ejemplo que esta
discusión no incluye las regiones
prorrusas del donbass esto significa que
según la versión ucraniana se está
debatiendo únicamente sobre la retirada
de las tropas rusas regulares que han
sido desplegadas después del 24 de
febrero que es cuando inició la invasión
de rusia en ucrania mientras en el
terreno la guerra continúa y se está
enseñando en particular con los civiles
esta mañana nos hemos despertado con
ataques en los suburbios de la capital
de ucrania kiev y también nos han
llegado informaciones durante la jornada
de otros bombardeos ocurridos en
mariupol en el sur y en hardcover
también continúa el drama humanitario de
los desplazados una última hora es que
el gobierno de república checa ha dicho
que no puede recibir a más refugiados
ucranianos ante el gran número de
personas que han cruzado su frontera en
las últimas semanas